for today's classic interview we are
going back maybe fittingly for what's
going on right now to non-science panic
over something that is not nearly as big
a problem as some people claimed it to
be make the connection if you want to
what's going on right now I'm speaking
about my interview with Ted Braugher uh
in the midst of the Ebola situation in
2014 Ted Brewer showed up on the David
Pakman show and did just totally
alarmist non-science craziness and I
think that this will remind us a lot
about what's going on right now and in
retrospect now with twenty-twenty
hindsight we see why the stuff that Ted
Braugher was saying was so crazy and out
of this world so let's go back to my
interview from July of 2014 with Ted
Braugher about Ebola I'm pleased to
welcome Ted Brewer to the program he's a
biochemist scientist author and consumer
health advocate he's concerned about the
potential of infectious disease
including Ebola crossing the southern
border of the United States Ted a real
pleasure to have you on today let's
start as broadly as possible what's your
concern with the border and Ebola well
the problem I have David is right now
over in Africa it spread to seven
different countries the CDC or the
people in charge in Africa telling us
over a thousand people are infected it's
gone to some of the major cities in
Africa it's basically being uncontained
in Africa over close to 700 now or
confirmed dead this has been going on
months and months and months and the
growth is continuing the problem that i
have with any disease like this is this
transmission via airplane or via other
folks that are coming into the country
that are not being checked for health
plus i personally believe the African
countries that are infected with Ebola
they really need to go in and they need
to start grounding and closing the
airport's until they get this under
control so this thing's not going to be
spread we know now that we have a couple
of medical personnel from the united
states that have also been infected with
Ebola and we also know that these
medical personnel were taking every
precaution they possibly could not to
get the disease and yet now they've also
become infected so we've got some
serious issues especially with the
border in the southern United States
then this isn't an immigration issue I'm
not getting into that whatsoever what I
want to talk about the fact that we need
to have some type of screening
process which is difficult since I
believe the executive offices said now
they want to have at least six million
folks come across the border by the end
of the summer well whatever numbers they
pick or whatever amount of people they
allow to come across the border there
need to be some type of screening
process for these folks coming across
the border to allow them basically to
learn what they're doing so let's go
through this step-by-step if we can I
guess that gives us kind of a good hang
on one second please leave please don't
ever do that again here so I'm so sorry
David it's craziness over there Ted so
Ted listen I want to go through the
step-by-step right because we have a
couple of different factors here now I'm
going to take you at your word that this
is not an immigration issue so I believe
you're being honest when you tell me
that so if we have to we have to have
immigration reform everybody knows that
in the United right now I understand but
Ted let let me let me now go through
what you said just so we can kind of
build on it if possible yeah so if the
issue here really is just the
possibility of contagion right let's
explore what's most likely now the CDC
in the United States has said that the
concern over Ebola in the Western
Hemisphere particularly coming through
the us-mexico border is incredibly low
on the list of concerns now you talked
about a screening process so let me pose
a question to you and then I'll let you
answer it as you see fit thank you if
your primary concern is what is most
likely to be an unscreened person
bringing disease into this country
people fly in Legally all the time from
Asia and the possibility that they would
bring in bird flu for example they are
not screened the possibility of that is
and when i say this i'm not exaggerating
orders of magnitude higher than someone
from central america coming through
mexico and bringing Ebola into the
united states since again there are no
cases of it in the Western Hemisphere
why are you here today talking to me
about the us-mexico border and Ebola
instead of Asia and bird flu for example
right well that's excellent could you
know you're at you're absolutely right
I'm not I have no argument with you
whatsoever concerning this here's the
way here's how I'm looking at all of
this bird flu does not have a ninety
percent fatality rate there are very
good medical protocols that are used
when a person is
you know comes down with bird flu to
help them recover from the bird flu this
isn't bird flu this is a this is this
could run Leisha pandemic I mean we have
it uncontrolled in seven countries in
Africa right now and my only concern is
this the border guards have said they
have other people coming in from other
countries that are not from Mexico that
are trying to sneak in through our
southern borders yeah now true but but
David I don't know if that's true or not
I'm not there I'm just reading I just
read the same stuff that you've read by
the same people that are supposed to be
experts in that who work in that area
yeah so to clarify just so we're on the
same page it what you're saying is true
people are coming through the us-mexico
border from other countries but again
according to the CDC and all experts
it's all from countries that have zero
instances of Ebola and these are
individuals who most likely don't have
the means to fly to Africa contract
Ebola come back to Central America come
through Mexico and into the u.s. this is
why to me as an observer it seems
hypocritical for individuals who now
want to make Ebola a us-mexico security
issue when they've been ignoring all of
the other real disease threats then I
haven't been ignoring any of them we
also have tuberculosis but that's been
shown in these folks come in from Mexico
we have dengue fever we have Alton last
year I went to South America I went to
Ecuador they gave me a whole bunch of
shots they wanted me to take before I
was even allowed to get off the cruise
ship that in Ecuador because they said
you can't go into Ecuador because of
these different diseases that are
prevalent here yeah we know that people
aren't just coming from Mexico they're
coming all the different parts of South
America what I'm saying is this if we're
going to allow immigration from Mexico
which I don't particularly have a
problem with that's not what this show
is about okay so we need to have some
type of screening protocol for
everything for tuberculosis for Ebola
all these different types of diseases
which we really don't need in the United
States having open borders without any
type of immigration screening to me
doesn't make any sense I know when my
mother came here from Germany back in
the early 50s basically after World War
Two she had to be completely medically
examined make sure she didn't have any
diseases coming in from Central Europe
when might i have a friend of mine who
ended up bringing a wife n from thailand
years ago and she had to be completely
screened and check for medical and
conditions before she was even allowed
to leave Thailand she had to get a
basically a letter of good health from
the Thai government before
you come in the United States okay good
so I take you at your word that this is
just genuine concern so let me open let
me know if we have some type of
isolation protocol that we keep people
in the basically and some type of
isolation facility for 10 days 12 days
14 days whatever times it takes for some
of these diseases to actually manifest
in the body and they're not just
carriers and basic some type of
isolation is have a quarantine protocol
that's fine yeah but but let me put but
so I want to get to that ok so what's
the principle that Ted Brewer uses to
determine who should be screened and for
what when they enter the u.s. in other
words you've spoken very specifically
about the us-mexico border and Central
Americans but what's the principle you
would use that you would apply to
everyone that's an excellent question i
think everybody coming in to live in the
united states of america who's coming
from any country which may carry
third-world diseases like mexico or
Ecuador or Panama or any place and it is
any place like that basically we have to
understand that we've got to avoid these
disease from being traffic ated into the
United States now David you know as well
as I do okay but now hold on Ted let's I
want it I don't want to get let you get
too far ahead of each piece because I
figure it's good to kind of analyze each
one of them so what specific diseases
native to or common in Central and South
America are the ones that York you've
identified as to why this should be a
policy specifically with those
immigrants well i feel i believe they
also be screened for tuberculosis number
one that's that's that's how that needs
to be number two I believe they need to
screen for dengue fever I believe that
all of these folks need to screen for
those too and I also believe that need
to put in some time aight isolation just
to make sure they don't have other types
of diseases such as Ebola but now as far
as Ebola coming over to this country
that's probably the last disease we want
to have come over here and again
unchecked immigration from any third
world country David it's going to
increase the likelihood of certain
diseases coming into the United States
or do we want it to or not we really
need to have some type of screening
protocol I mean normally people are
screened they've got to go through a
program in order to become an American
citizen or to get into the United States
that's not happening right now yeah but
Ted I'm curious you know as it happened
I looked up the
Lumbergh healthcare efficiency rankings
of different countries as it turns out
the Mexican healthcare system is ranked
as significantly more efficient than the
US healthcare system baby will detect
even the day have you been to Mexico
that hold on a second now now here's
where we Ted although you may be able to
anecdotally tell me about specific
places in Mexico where there are
terrible things if we look at the
rankings and i'll tell you how they're
measured okay just so we're a hundred
percent clear if we weigh life
expectancy relative per capita cost of
healthcare absolute per capita cost of
healthcare and healthcare results right
the mexican healthcare system is
actually more efficient than the US
healthcare system now i want to be very
clear hold on now Ted hold on now dead
I'm going to give you a chance to
respond I just want to make sure I'm
clear about what barometer i'm using
because the US spends so much on
healthcare that's correct that brings
down the efficiency how I understand the
mathematics of it that's what my
question to you is this do you advocate
screening people who are in the US on a
some kind of regular basis who have not
come from other countries because dengue
fever is already in the US a
drug-resistant tuberculosis is already
in the US you cited those two should the
government say you know what we're
screening anybody who goes to public
school for these things or what should
the rule be to be fair no I'm not
agreeing with that at all number one is
you're giving me statistics based on
Mexican statistics when message Mexico
is a third world country they have very
little money to put into their health
care system so they're actually going to
rate higher in the United States as far
as total per capita income spent on
healthcare that's a completely erroneous
argument on that David well hold on a
second but but so why has no you're just
saying you don't believe the facts
basement where's the whole argument yeah
the United States is pretty much leading
the world when it comes to heart disease
2 diabetes and to cancer from any
industrialization we have millions and
tens of millions of people taking the
drug Prozac and Zoloft and adderall and
ritalin and concerta for children we've
got all these people taking different
statin drugs which all have their own
host of diseases yeah these different
conditions are be treated by being
treated by all of these diseases but yet
we're still ranked as one of the sickest
nations from the industrialized
standpoint in the entire world so I'm
not saying to you that the United States
is the beach
of health but this certainly isn't I'll
say the leading cause of death in
children aged 14 and under other than
cancer in the United States I mean other
than accidents as cancer in the United
States we have the highest leukemia
rating children of any country in the
world but Mexico I have been to Mexico
I've been to Mexico repeatedly so I
disease rates they have down there they
have all kinds of diseases that we
pretty much eradicate it in the country
and answer your second question if a
person is contacts dengue fever they
come out with some type of disease that
we know that's highly contagious yes if
they go to their doctors they're
diagnosed with those types of diseases I
believe they should be quarantined until
they get past that disease that's how I
feel about that if you don't agree with
me that's okay but that's what we need
to do I'm not saying that the Mexicans
are any lettuce less or any better than
we are I'm saying that our health care
system in the United States is broken it
doesn't work hey now Ted Ted you're
saying a lot of stuff I like now we're
agreeing okay but what I'm saying is if
a person comes across the borders and
their exhibit of being sick with fever
or chills or they've got lice or
whatever they need to be treated they
need to put into quarantine to make sure
they're okay that goes with everybody
but the United States are you kidding me
we got 30 40 million people taking
statin drugs which have been shown to
cause kidney failure are you joking me
now we got dialysis centers all over the
United States set up because of the
drugs that people are taken I mean we've
turned into an entire drugs culture in
the United States for prescription drugs
hey all right said you know now now now
we're talking yeah you know I wish I
we're getting a lot of points of
agreement here on a kind of different
top o the reality is this the United
States has one of the worst health care
systems in the world we have one of the
worst preventive healthcare systems in
the world instead of spending hundreds
of thousands of dollars on a person
before they die trying to keep them
alive for a couple more weeks we should
teach them how to eat right when they're
in grade school for heaven's sake we
should learn teach them how to eat the
right kind of food we need to learn and
tell them to stay away from GMO food
stay with all the chemicals in the diet
and all the all the sugar and the high
fructose corn syrup those are the
biggest problems in our country but what
I'm saying is the immune system of the
United States it's pretty lousy you know
sixty percent of the population of this
country is obese yeah now we're going to
throw a throw a disease in this country
with everybody's immune system already
impaired is going to sweep through the
United States like in the United States
has no health care system whatsoever so
the reality is is this Mexico has a
lousy healthcare
per capita we may be worse but the
reality is we're not any better than
Mexico's horizontal sir because we're
leading the world in industrialized
nations all right I got it I got it I
got Ted listen I wish we had more time I
agree with a lot of what you're saying
as my audience knows i think the Ebola
concerns are a little bit of what I call
concern trolling I know you disagree but
it's been a fascinating conversation Ted
Brewer has been our guest thanks so much
for joining us thank you David